Last Man Standing
it's 1917 and two young soldiers have
been given an almost impossible mission
to save their comrades written and
directed by Sam Mendes it's an epic but
also very personal tale inspired by
stories his grandfather told him when he
was a boy about his own experiences of
the First World War he hadn't talked
about them for 50 or 60 years and he
only talked about them with his
grandchildren really he used to wash his
hands all the time and I asked my dad
you know why descr and I wash his hands
he sits because he remembers the mud of
the trenches and he could never get his
hands clean and that really struck me as
well that it was still in his body was
in his every fiber of his being almost
unconsciously even though it would have
been so long ago so they yeah they
stayed with me
the movie is filmed as if it's one
continuous shot an incredible technical
feat masterminded by Mendes and the
legendary cinematographer Roger Deakins
you wanted to be immersive you know and
you want to make it feel as if the
audience is with an alongside these
actors and experiencing time with the
characters you know just feeling every
second passing taking every step with
them once you sort of subconsciously
understand that this is in real time you
you know that whatever's going on
however sort of treacherous or or even
enjoyable you can't you can't get away
from it you are with them all of the
time and that brought unique and
challenging conditions for all involved
the last thing you want to do is forget
a line yeah you know misplace a prop or
something you know then be nine minutes
into a scene and then just [ __ ] it right
up you won't want to do that but they
happened you know what we had to do
which is try and carry on and you know
in the final cut of the film there are
mistakes in the film you know whether it
slips trips you know bumping into people
yeah but that's that's something that
makes it authentic and really stick to
our it would have been because that's
what was happening to us and the day
Lisa Casa Sky News
[Music]